the final Arc In Black Clover is out of  control after introducing us to yami's  overpowered little sister and her  ability to combine key with dark magic  Black Clover just took it a step further  by having Asta combine his key with  anti-magic and this will be asta's next  big power-up he will learn how to  manipulate his key in totally new ways  like yami's sister does but instead of  magic he will Infuse it with anti-magic  by using these unique key manipulation  techniques from Hino country Asta will  gain an advantage over Lucius because  key manipulation techniques are foreign  to him and so asta's final training Arc  has already begun if you want more long  form and short form black lore content  don't forget to subscribe to anime  uproar right now just click the red  subscribe button at the bottom of your  screen